der Pipeline Krimi in der Ostsee der
Pipeline Thriller er geht weiter jetzt
gibt es ein viertes Leck und damit ist
auch dem letzten klar das ist Sabotage
das ist ein Anschlag die Frage ist
allerdings von wem und warum klar ist
das Geschehen wird auch in der Ukraine
genauestens verfolgt denn einer der
Verdächtigen staatsakteure ist Russland
und in Kiew begrüßen wir jetzt Paul
Ronzheimer zum Gespräch mit dem Kiefer
Bürgermeister Vitali Klitschko schönen
guten Tag euch beiden
schönen guten Morgen aus Kiew Vitali
Klitschko der Bürgermeister der Stadt
sitzt bei mir Vitali die große Debatte
ist wer steckt dahinter hinter dem
Sabotage von Nord Stream es gibt den
Verdacht dass das Russland sein könnte
was ist dein Verdacht
ich habe keine richtige Informationen
weil das ist normalerweise Aufgabe für
Geheimdienste das ist fest zu stellen
wer dahinter steckt aber von wer
interessiert wer interessiert den ganz
Europa jetzt Haus zu bringen und
abhängig von Gas Europa zu machen das
ist klar und deutlich Russland und
deswegen ich schließe nicht aus dass es
eine wird ganz bald Informationen kommen
wer dahinter steckt und schließlich
nicht aus das ist Russland hat solche
Interesse die alles im Haus zu bringen
und zu zeigen ja sehen sie doch
ihr seid
abhängig von uns und
deswegen die alle Sanktionen das ist
selbst schuld sogenannte selbst Schuld
von Europäer weil wir sind bereit Gas zu
liefern weil wir sind bereit
Services zu liefern und Sanktion sogar
solche translager Macht
Schwierigkeit für Europäische Union die
große Angst in diesen Tagen auch in
Europa ist die Frage ob Wladimir Putin
ob Russland bereit ist am Ende eine
taktische Atomwaffe zu nutzen gegen die
Ukraine wie viel Angst hat Vitali
Klitschko vor dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen
wir sind gerade Angst
das ist hier denke ich mal
wenn Russland nutzt die Atomwaffen das
bedeutet dass es Gefahr nicht die für
die Ukraine das ist Gefahr für die ganze
Welt und das kann jede Menschen unsere
Erde betreten werden und deswegen
[Musik]
haben wir sehr viel Sorgen und aber das
ist eine klare Chance was die Russen
sagen und wenn die machen das bedeutet
die wird diese Krieg noch eine
nächste Stufe von Exklusion bekommen es
gibt ja Unterschiede zwischen einer
taktischen Atomwaffe und eine Atombombe
die sozusagen hunderte Kilometer oder
noch mehr betreffen kann wie viel Sinn
macht das das Wladimir Putin diese
taktische Atomwaffe einsetzen konnte
jetzt im Moment
das ist eine Hysterie weil Putin hat
keine Erfolg in diese Krieg und sieht
der verliert das klare Klärung wieso
weil der russische Soldaten ist nicht
motiviert ich bin als ehemalige Kämpfe
möchte sagen in einer Schlacht das ist
sehr
entscheidende Rolle spielt die Willi und
äh
kampfmühle Charakter und
die Russinnen motiviert nicht die
verstehen dass es eine fremdes Land und
heute werden
Flüchtlinge das ist normalerweise die
Flüchtlinge kommen von die ein Land wo
ist der Krieg Krieg befindet sich in
durch eine aber die
hunderte von 1.000 Flüchtlinge von
Russland weil die russische Bevölkerung
will nicht kämpfen die unterstützt diese
das ist
Frage die Unterstützung der Krieg aber
in Realität keine will sterben keine
will teilnehmen in diese sinnlose Krieg
auch von russischen Seiten jetzt gibt es
in Deutschland eine Debatte darum ob man
diese russischen Flüchtlinge die eben
nicht in der russischen Armee dienen
sollen aufnehmen soll Kanzler oder
Scholz hat sich dafür ausgesprochen wie
sieht man das in der Ukraine ich sehe so
aus die jede Politiker auch in
russischer Politiker abhängig von seiner
Bevölkerung von meinen von Bevölkerung
und die Leute müssen kämpfen muss sagen
seine Meinung wegen diese Krieg und
fordern von dem russischen Regierung
Krieg zu stoppen und seine
Militäreinheiten zurückzusehen und wir
erwarten von russische Bevölkerung und
auf jeden Fall
kommt eine Zeit wo jede Russe sagt
gibt die Frage für Regierung wieso Welt
beste
1000 anderen Unternehmen jetzt sehen aus
aus Russland und noch dazu kommt die
Frage wieso ist mal wichtigste Frage
wichtigste Frage kommt auf jeden Fall
wieso ist mein Bruder mein Mann mein
Verwandte mein Freund ist gestorben in
diese sinnlose Krieg welche sind also
sollte Deutschland die Flüchtlinge nicht
aufnehmen damit sie im eigenen Land
gegen Putin kämpfen meiner Meinung nach
ist jede russische Bürger muss seine
Meinung sagen wegen dieser also das ist
das ist sehr sehr schwache Position das
ist aus Russland zu fliegen und das gibt
keine Krieg in Russland gibt keine
Gefahr in russische Bevölkerung aber die
müssen sagen nein wir gehen nicht im
Krieg aber normal
noch einmal Deutschland sollte die dann
nicht aufnehmen
ist sehr dünne Eis von meiner Seite dass
man muss
mit
es ist auch man muss Unterstützung von
einer Seite aber wenn wird in ihnen in
ins Land der gegen die kämpfen nicht zu
kämpfen einfach seine Meinung zu sagen
wie bereitet sich in diesen Tagen Kiew
darauf vor dass es eine weitere
Eskalation oder möglicherweise auch eine
Atomwaffen Eskalation geben könnte du
hast da auch eine persönliche Geschichte
dein Vater war damals als Tschernobyl in
die Luft geflogen ist dort als
Soldat im Einsatz was macht das mit
einem
das ist
wenn wird
Atomwaffen benutzt das ist wird
verbreitet nichts für
Notarin von induch eine das ist wird
Alarme die ganze Welt und sehr viel
ständig wir haben riesige Sorgen
aber meine Meinung nach das ist reine
chantage
letzte Frage Vitali Klitschko werden wir
uns die Situation anschauen jetzt an der
Front
die Menschen fragen sich kann die
Ukraine das jetzt tatsächlich gewinnen
oder was wird Putin tun bei der Annexion
oder nach der Annexion dieser Gebiete
wovon gehst du aus
ich möchte noch einmal sagen Putin hat
alle Regeln gebrochen internationale
Verträge hier internationale
Regeln weil
sogar
ich möchte zurückzukommen zum Geschichte
1996 als gerade
auch eine freiwillig seine Atomwaffen
abgegeben Russland war eine Seite auch
garantiert unsere Souveränität unter der
Integrität von unseres Land für Ukraine
hat
[Musik]
angegriffen wo keine angegriffen und
man muss die Russland
respektiert nur die Stärke
und die
überhaupt die
machen keine keine Aufmerksamkeit für
die Schwäche Position deswegen wir
müssen stark sein wir müssen unsere
territoreien beteiligen und diese
genannte Referendum in in die Krieg wo
ist die größte Teil von Bevölkerung ist
weg die versuchen zu legalisieren schon
wieder legalisieren seine Lügerei
wegen die spezielle Operation wegen die
Kampf gegen Nationalisten
Faschisten und
das ist ein Teil von seiner Propaganda
in seinen Lügerei das ist nicht mehr
Wladimir Putin ich habe den Ukraine
Präsidenten selenskel letzte Woche
gefragt ob er ein Lieblingswitz hat über
Vladimir Putin dann hat er sehr gelacht
aber wollte den Witz nicht erzählen hast
du einen Lieblingswitz über WL
und sehr viel wurde erzählen dass es wie
wir es jetzt
Mobilisierung hilft in der Russland und
wir Ukraine machen Witz darüber wenn
eine professionelle Armee hat nie
geschafft jetzt eine Armatur Armee das
ist um nichts vorbereitete Menschen muss
die Krieg gewinnen gegen durch eine und
das ist
ist nicht lächerlich aber das ist leider
harde Wahrheit
er schickt Kinder 20-Jährige Menschen
ohne Verbreitung zum Front und
für ihm spielt die größte Wert in der
Welt die Menschen leben und für ihn
spielt
überhaupt keine Rolle die Interessen von
Menschen die die Schicksal von Menschen
die er hat seine eigene Interesse am
Macht zu bleiben weil jetzt im Moment
beim verliert er der Krieg es geht Ernst
um seine Zukunft seine persönliche
Zukunft und deswegen für ihn ist die
Frage zum überleben aber nicht für den
Preis die menschliche Leben um die
Preise menschliche Leben
akzeptiert oder überhaupt nicht
internationelle
[Applaus]
Kontakten
menschliche Leben in Europa die
Schicksale von Millionen von Menschen in
der Welt in Europa in Ukraine in seine
eigene Land in Russland auch wo wo denke
ich mal die diese Krieg ist eine trige
auf erste Stelle für Bevölkerung auch in
Russland herzlichen Dank Vitali
Klitschko Bürgermeister von Kiew und
damit zurück nach Berlin
[Musik]